the attachment theory argues that a
strong emotional and physical bond to
one primary caregiver in our first years
of life is critical to our development
if our bonding is strong and we are
securely attached then we feel safe to
explore the world we know that there is
always that safe base which we can
return to anytime if our bond is weak we
feel in securely attached we are afraid
to leave or explore a rather
scary-looking world because we are not
sure if we can return people who are
securely attached is said to have
greater trust can connect to others and
as a result a more successful in life
insecurely attached people tend to
mistrust others lack social skills and
have problems forming relationships
there is one type of secure attachment
and there are three types of insecure
attachments anxious ambivalent anxious
avoidant and anxious disorganized in
responses to distress the first three
react organized while the last acts
disorganized
to understand the theory better let's
look at mr. and mrs. Smith who have four
children Luka and Joe and Amy the Smiths
are lovely parents who cuddle make
frequent eye contact speak warmly and
are always there for their kids but one
day mr. Smith falls very sick and dies
for mrs. Smith life now becomes very
difficult
she spends all day working while at the
same time trying to care for her
children an impossible task at six years
of age
Lucas brain is for the most part
developed his character strong and his
worldview shaped the new situation does
not affect him much he knows there is
still always mum his safe haven he feels
securely attached later he turns into a
trusting and optimistic young man his
self-image is positive Anne who is three
has problems coping with a new lack of
attention to one her mother now act
unpredictably she is anxious about their
relationship and as a result becomes
clingy to get her mums attention she has
to raise her emotional state and scream
when her mom finally reacts with a
predictable response she herself acts
ambivalent and doesn't show her true
feelings later in life
others think Anne is unpredictable or
moody her self-image is less positive
her attachment style is anxious
ambivalent
two-year-old Joe spends his days with
his uncle who loves him but thinks that
a good education means being strict if
Little Joe shows too much emotion or is
too loud
his uncle gets angry and sometimes
punitive this scares Joe he learns that
to avoid fear he has to avoid showing
his feelings also in other situations as
an adult he continues this strategy and
has problems entering relationships his
image of himself is rather negative his
attachment is anxious avoidant Amy who
is just one year old gets sent to a
nursery the staff there is poorly
trained overworked and often very
stressed some are outright abusive Amy
therefore becomes anxious of the very
people she seeks security from a
conflict which totally disorganized is
her ideas about love and safety and she
is experiencing fear without resolution
she tries to avoid all social situations
as an adult she thinks of herself as
unworthy of love her self-image is very
negative her attachment is anxious
disorganized our attachment is formed in
the very first years of our lives a time
when we are too young to communicate our
anxiety and as a result can experience
high levels of stress then our adrenal
gland an organ sitting on top of our
kidneys produces the stress hormones
adrenaline and cortisol the heart rate
increases the blood pressure goes up and
we become alert if that happens
frequently it is called toxic stress
toxic because it impairs the development
of a child's brain and weakens the
immune system in embryos are at a very
young age toxic stress can even switch
the expressions of genes which can
affect our health many decades later
by simulating a strange situation we can
assess an attachment style already by
the age of one to do this we let the
child play with their mother for a few
minutes inside a room then the child is
left alone the key moment is the child's
reaction when her mother returns
securely attached children first usually
hug their mother then can calm down and
eventually get back to playing in
securely attached children can be
ambivalent and avoidant some can't stop
crying or refuse to continue playing the
long-term effects of our attachment in
the early years are well documented
using the theory researchers at
Minnesota University were able to
predict already at age three if a child
would drop out of high school with 77%
accuracy in another study undergraduates
at Harvard were asked to assess how
close they felt to their parents 35
years later they were asked about their
health 91% of those who said they had a
rather broken relationship with their
mother were also diagnosed with health
issues including coronary artery disease
hypertension and alcoholism for those
that had reported a warm relationship
the figure of poor health diagnosis was
just 45% but there is another reason why
the early years deserve special
attention they are the starting place
for subsequent behaviors a kid that
feels securely attached at age 2 can
make friends at kindergarten their
worldview gets reinforced with every
interaction and they develop optimism as
a result they make good relationships at
school then at college and later at work
highly in securely attached children can
miss out on this opportunity
psychologist John Bowlby a pioneer an
attachment theory allegedly said what
cannot be communicated to the mother
cannot be communicated to the self in
other words those who feel insecurely
attached might not quite understand
themselves to get to know who they are
and what they feel they might have to go
way back in time
you
you